hey guys it is the 17th of May today my
name is Jess and you are watching games
but news Ubisoft has revealed that the
divisions next free update called
conflict will arrive on May twenty-fifth
conflict adds a new incursion called
clear sky as well as new gear sets at
weapons list and a mission where you'll
need to take down enemy leaders in a set
amount of time a new hijack feature is
also being added for extractions from
the dark zone which will allow players
to cut an extraction rope to spill all
the loot on the ground and yes that does
sound really really annoying the clear
sky raid will be set in columbus circle
and calls for you to take back a
formerly LMK be controlled anti-air
missile site still to come are the
underground survival and last and
expansions which won't be free there's a
new trailer for the conflict update on
gang [ __ ] next up a japanese analyst has
revealed on twitter that resident evil 7
is in development and will be revealed
next month at e3 dr. serkan toto wrote
on twitter about resident evil 7 yes
it's in development the entire game will
go back to ari's hora roots and
essentially be a clean slate adding they
will show it at e3 the resident evil 7
team hired Jordan tomorrow a designer
who previously worked on metal gear
solid 5 and PT at cucina production in
October of last year veteran producer
MRSA chica kuwata said fans should stay
tuned for Rosie 7 News that said Capcom
are yet to confirm development on any
new resident evil titles although they
did say they were planning a full-scale
offensive for the second half of the
year finally it turns out EA wasn't all
that into battlefield ones premise when
it was first pitched by dies at ea's
annual invested a briefing EA Studios
boss Patrick soderlund explains if you
look at what other partners in the end
are doing they're going into scifi we've
had a lot of success in the modern
military space but we felt like there
was a need for a change when the team
presented the idea to me of world war
one I absolutely rejected it I said
world war one its trench warfare it
can't be fun to play obviously soda has
changed his tune and now believes the
setting is right for the franchise and
the publisher adil build one is due to
hit shelves on a pataga 21 that is
everything I have for you today but do
let me know down in that comment section
if you like the world war one setting
for battlefield you can add to gamespot
we've got stories on 46 and potential
movie there's everything I've got for
you today but you leave me your thoughts
and feelings on today's story and I will
see you again tomorrow